one dead and a fire near the strip good
evening thanks for joining us here at
five i'm denise faldis and i'm brian
loftis we start tonight with that
developing story that fire killing one
person injuring several more and leaving
about a dozen people without a home
now it happened near twain and arville
that's where we find the i-team's david
charns with the very latest on this
active investigation
david yeah brian and denise right now we
know that one person has died in this
fire the red cross helping 14 others who
lived in this complex
if you look behind me you can see what
is left of this building
firefighters say the roof collapsed
there you can see part of the window
shade
that left four people hurt we'll show
you photos of what firefighters saw when
they got here late this morning
they tell us they heard people inside
trapped inside there of course they ran
in
you see flames and smoke coming from the
roof firefighters say the layout of this
complex because the buildings are so
close together
made it hard for them over the years
there's been fires in this apartment
complex
it's challenging for our men and women
when they respond just
due to the layout
take a look at this video a neighbor
shooting this as fire crews were getting
here you can hear the sirens you see
that man
barefoot helping firefighters with their
work
and tending to what we believe is a
person a victim there on the ground
the woman who took this video tells me
it brings some light
to this tragedy you see somebody like
jump into action and just
naturally you just hope that everybody
is like that i think you know and
and to see a neighbor so close willing
to you know run around
the trash cans barefoot it made me feel
good
into like many others here across the
valley seeing the smoke from this fire
around 11 o'clock who that man is though
we do not now know right now you can
still smell the smoke from this fire now
six hours later the investigation is
just getting underway
that's going to take a couple days of
course depending on what caused that
fire when they do figure out a cause
of course we'll let you know live near
arville and twain tonight i'm david
charns 8 news